[Musique]
passer bon moment quand même c'est vrai
allez-y
[Musique]
quatre tortues d'enfer dans la ville
chevallier des cayes et de vinyles ce
sont des guerriers fantastique et ce
alors que les niçois bon c'est là parce
que euro évolue vers la sortie
[Musique]
1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
j'adore tortues ninja cette série fait
partie de mes séries préférées comme le
prouve ce tableau qui changent à chaque
épisode en fonction de mes besoins
scénaristique
je suis sûr que vous adorez tortues
ninja tout le monde aime les tortues
ninja et comme chez joueur du grenier on
est des gros trous du cul qui adorent
ont brisé les rêves des gens et bien
c'est parti pour hors sujet sur tous les
trucs les plus pourris de la licence
tortues ninja la gamine way à disneyland
nikkei n'existe pas il ya quelqu'un dans
son costume tue c'est à j'adore ça
offert cet épisode nous avons regardé
tout ce qui a été fait autour des
tortues ninja et je vous le dis on a
nagé dans la merde
regarder une série que nous avons adoré
étant gosse se faire lentement arraché
les ongles par des producteurs avides de
fric s'était pas spécialement une
expérience agréable je vous avoue alors
avant de rentrer dans ce que j'appelle
le cimetière du fun et bien on va
d'abord regarder ce qui a été fait de
beer et on va descendre les couches une
par une mère car les mais vers les
égouts lol les égouts les tortues ninja
à cole harbour fermer la ferme et la
tortue ninja à la base c'est un comics
américain sorti en 84 assez violent et
très dark les tortues étaient assez
cruel et n'hésitez pas à vraiment pété
des gueules trois ans plus tard il ya
une grosse hype qui se développe autour
de tout ça avec par exemple le jeu vidéo
en 90 mais surtout avec une première
adaptation pour la télé diffusée en
france sur france 3 il y en a eu
d'autres depuis la série de 2003 par
exemple dont je trouve le générique
absolument à chier suis désolé
[Musique]
mika
c'est roy de l'action
[Musique]
bref ensuite il ya eu aussi la série de
2012 mais c'est l'adaptation de 1987 qui
reste malgré tout la plus connue voilà
ça c'est vrai générique un vrai
générique ça doit être plein de fausses
promesses et de plans super travail et
regarde ça les tortues qui saute sur le
tech de rome comme ça y est la question
ça se passe c'est trop cool et c est le
techno drôme il va rester enfermé deux
saisons dans une [ __ ] n cavernes une
saison dans une autre dimension et puis
après il va se balader comme ça sur
terre un peu partout ce mal
[Musique]
bien se lancer
tu verras jamais à la baston
d'ailleurs pour l'anecdote c'est la
série de 87 qui a introduit le principe
des bardeaux de couleur pour
différencier les tortues à la base dans
le comics les quatre tortues autant
bande rouge comme sur la jaquette du jeu
nes à ce dessin animé ça c'était bien de
mon temps c'était mieux avant ouais
c'est ce que vous croyez ont vérifié
juste pour être sûr
et regardez cette corde je crois qu'elle
signe le passage des ninjas si
redoutable combattant que rien n'arrête
qui sait cette corde qui vous fait
l'affirmer mais vous n'avez qu'à
regarder vous même
elle a été fabriquée au japon voyez vous
voilà on continue aa oui je suis raciste
bon donc à l'envoyons l'épisode 1 on
retrouve à april qui est chassé par des
méchants de street of rage et qui
s'enfuit grâce à ses super pouvoirs de
poules sorcières après il s'enfuit mais
deux joueurs pas vu le mur et au moment
où tout semble perdu
les tortues arrive dans l'ombre pour les
déjà et regretté de vous être attaqués à
niort saleté de bâton après dans
l'épisode 1 on va retrouver tous les
trucs habituels qu'on retrouvera dans un
peu tous les épisodes à l'étendue qui
mène une enquête
alors
avec ça vous avez l'air presque humain
non et évidemment l'introduction de
schnyder qui était un des vilains que je
trouvais vraiment le plus badass encore
jeune je connais cette technique de
combat c'est celle du clandestine est
sérieux c'est la première fois que tu
rencontres les tortues ninja c'est tout
ce que tu as à venir ces tortues géantes
c'est pas vraiment bien aux mondiaux les
tortues géantes
ok je serai d'heure ils pètent le style
mais je crois qu'il est aussi vraiment
qu'on fait dans cette série étonné le
genre de scène plus tard il va empêcher
les sorties de découvrir le tango grosse
les tortues ninja d'abattre yoshi jeunes
on les a empêchés de découvrir montech
notre homme à toutes les équipes de
sécurité rendez-vous immédiatement tout
comme et pourquoi tu cours le sale
débile et sert à quoi de te filmer pour
qu'elle te voyais là tu étais sur
chatroulette
enfin voilà donc je vais pas tout vous
décrire parce que je vais être honnête
c'est un très bon épisode la série de 87
étaient relativement sympa comme avait
plein de très bons épisodes
si je dis juste que c'est relativement
sympa c'est parce que autant au début
c'est plutôt cool les épisodes sont
vraiment bien
autant après quelques saisons c'est
plutôt il faut vite le réexpédier dans
sa propre dimension
vient la ville va être transformé en
immense salade de fruits aïe
mais bon voilà maintenant qu'on a fixé
un genre de valeur étalon
on va vraiment pouvoir commencer à
récurer les chiottes allez c'est parti
pour les films alors tortues ninja sur
enlève le film qui vient juste de sortir
et celui d'avant en 3d ces trois films
sortis entre 90 et 93 le premier plutôt
sympa les tortues se bat bien le mort
est pas trop lourd shader est cool c'est
bien le deuxième était correct bon
l'humour devient un peu plus cartoon est
ce que c'est vrai les combats c'est bon
vous fait quoi là non les mecs sérieux
derrière n'a vous faites quoi vous on
sert à rien restauration médias
[Musique]
c'est pas une disparue sur ninja lequel
aura juste balance et un lacrymogènes
sur la gueule ça c'est une technique de
crs pas de ninja ce le deuxième film
n'étant qu'une hijja sont débiles mais
ça passe à sont débiles comme des ados
un peu te b qui jouent au foot dans la
maison donc quelque part c'est logique
et enfin arriva le troisième film qu'est
ce qui te mine de charbon
j'ai ressenti un grand bouleversement de
la force comme si un drame terrible
s'était produit bref alors que tous les
enfants du monde entier attendaient
l'arrivée de craon gants super vilains
les producteurs du film répondait à
leurs attentes en leur offrant le très
attendu prince de lu et japanese steurs
donc le film commence avec à peu près la
même qualité qu'un épisode de hercules
la série télévisée au japon on suit les
aventures palpitantes de japonais numéro
un qui a
attendez on vient de me dire qu'on en a
rien à [ __ ] en fait scène suivante
pendant ce temps là à new york on
retrouve à le sprinteur pardon ma
marionnette et sur 1 100 % moins cher
ces raisons à chaque fois que splinter
apparaît dans le film toujours il est
caché derrière une fenêtre ou n'importe
quoi pour com - apax à mario d'elles n'a
pas de bas du corps c'est ridicule si tu
ajoutes ça au fait qu'il a une tête de
malades en phase terminale tu as envie
d'organiser le téléthon juste pour lui
il a vraiment enfin bref donc appris il
arrive avec le tas de merde qu'elle a
acheté dans une brocante et l'offre
tortue c'est quoi ce machin une espèce
de vieux sable
un truc dont les japonais servir pour
créer des codes
au même moment dans le passé machin
active la lampe et échange sa place dans
le présent avec april si j'en juge par
son sam
il habite dans ce japon du moyen-âge
ouais ça ou alors il est juste passé
dans une japan expo fait comment tu peux
déduire ça elle a été fabriquée au japon
où voyez vous ah oui ça a du sens en
fait bref les tortues parts dans le
passé afin de sauver april et essaye de
sa vitre le château où elle est censée
être détenus
voilà c'est ça les tortues ninja c'est
des valeurs de sacrifice de bravoure
d'héroïsme au kimono bonsaï sushis
c'est pas grave je veux dire c'est les
années 90 aussi faut remettre ça dans le
contexte c'était suzuki- mais n'en
rajoute pas mais bon à la limite le
racisme ça va c'est pas du tout ce que
je voulais dire je veux dire bon quand
j'étais petit je comprenais pas ce genre
de blague alors je m'en fichais mais
déjà à l'époque les autres blagues des
tortues au rang des complètement ouf
finalement c'est vachement tordez
l'année d'une tortue tu accumules rappel
sur le flanc droit quoi sur la côte
ouest qui a dû flancs de sa gueule
[ __ ] et ben alors quoi tu espérais
peut-être voir la famille adams est déçu
et puis tu vas autant dans le premier
film ça va c'est michelangelo qui fait
des blagues de merde ça va c'est le
personnage qui veut ça dans le deuxième
film il ya aussi des blagues pourries
mais car une tortue sur une blague de
maire d'eybens les autres tortues levade
parce que sa blague était pour y aller
dans le troisième c'est un festival
c'est du niveau de batman et robin
bref pendant que dans le futur splinter
s'ennuie comme un rapport non pendant
qu'il s'était éteint paisiblement dans
son sommeil puis on a été empaillé je
crois
non mais sincèrement regarder cette
scène ya une baston à côté de ses yeux
sais même pas s'il tourne la tête
je te jure ce film c'est un plaidoyer en
faveur de l'euthanasie bon on en bref
dans le passé les tortures retrouve
michelangelo qui était au village des
rebelles et qui se fait attaquer c'est
la seule bataille
avec un peu de budget
je vous l'avais dit que les scènes de
batailles étaient misérables parce que
oui c'est tout ce qu'on a dans ce film
c'est des bastons nul des répliques qui
te ferait même pas sourire même site
était défoncée à la poudre lunaire et du
racisme sympa qu'on sait que ça va
passer parce que c'est sur les asiat
alors là tu as commis l'erreur de ta vie
nagasaki ok même moi j'aurais pas osé la
faire celle là et puis rien que moi j'y
suis le mec
enfin bref le mécha s'évapore en mode
cartoon fin du film et toute la salle
dans le cinéma fait la même tête que
raphaël en se demandant ce qu'ils
viennent de regarder et voilà c'était
tortues ninja 3 c'était de la merde le
film a été défoncée par les critiques
par le public et ça a été un échec
commercial absolument complet faisons
dans une série est bon qu'ils s'engagent
alors tu ninja nouvelle génération je
vraiment je comprends pas ce dvd je ne
peux pas expliquer ce dvd c'est comment
un mec s'est dit tiens on va reprendre
tout ce que les gens ont détesté et tout
ce qui n'a pas marché pour en faire 26
épisodes jeu ce dvd défi la science est
la logique
[Musique]
boullier m cela fait des jours que vous
ne vous alimentez pas que vous n'avez
pas dormi je m'inquiète pour votre santé
pourquoi ne répondez vous pas quel est
donc cet étrange miroir
pourquoi revient-il toute votre
attention voulait plus que nous on est
4e du 100 m on était deux des dessins on
devient des êtres humains
la cerise sur le gâteau sa peine plus
d'un bidon
je m'étais évanoui
bref passons sur cette magnifique intro
avec ce générique qui te spoil
complètement le scénario puisque tu vois
directement la cinquième tortue et on
retrouve deux tortues dans l'ombre qui
se disputent sagement va te faire cuire
un oeuf
[Applaudissements]
petit clin d'oeil aux premiers films
mais les tortues apparaissent dans
l'ombre pour la première fois donc
rafael leur belle et très énervé et on
se prend vraiment pourquoi il part en
moto
[Musique]
bah oui comme je disais le budget a
encore baissé donc là tu as les bouches
des tortues qui ne tiennent même plus
bon le seul point positif sur les
costumes ont essayé d'être gentil ses
sprinteurs qui quand même et en meilleur
état il faut le reconnaître que dans le
troisième film est d'ailleurs maintenant
il a un genre de spider sens chez moi
c'est pas du tout expliqué comment il
peut savoir ce qui s'est alors on n'a
pas le temps en transition baguettes
chinoises
ok alors où c'est extrêmement raciste ou
c'est complètement con mais c'est un des
deux donc c'est une ferrari pour sauver
raphaël qui se fait agresser
ranger ses costumes fabricant avait
utilisé du scotch j'en sais rien bref un
petit peu de baston et voilà on a vu
l'un trop haut on a vu les tortues on a
vu ce trader aussi qui ne sert à rien
dans l'intrigué qui ressemble peu un
danseur de zumba fitness avec son
justaucorps à paillettes là il est temps
donc maintenant de lancer l'intrigant
n'envoyant splinter faire un tri pour
incident dans une cinématique de jeux
playstation 1 ou un vieux ninja après il
à poil là d'accord lui apprend qu'un
ennemi encore plus ancien que je serai
d'heure les dragons veulent reprendre
possession de la terre les shader
pendant ce temps là qui est furieux de
n'avoir absolument rien à voir avec
l'intrigant même trouve l'emplacement de
l'égout des tortues et on a en fait la
première grosse baston dans la série
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
le castelet juge bébé
oui
la part de monsieur d'avancé sur bâle au
nom c'était bien sa pizza à la crème
fraîche avec un supplément de règle
[Musique]
merci de votre visite
tu as aimé les tortues ninja
sont mortes elles sont mortes c'est pas
les tortues ninja c'est quelqu'un qui
leur a mis la main dans le cul et qui
jouent avec leurs cadavres
j'ai vu comment cette quelques épisodes
juste pour voir et [ __ ] et 10 millions
d'années d'évolution pour en arriver là
c'est bien d'avoir un mec sinon je suis
censé passer un bon moment là c'est
sensé me faire rire [ __ ] j'ai plus
rigoler devant apocalypse seconde guerre
mondiale que devant ça là c'est les
funérailles de l'humour et convient de
ne pas excuser ça en disant que c'est
pour les plus jeunes et moi je suis
désolé j'avais 10 ans je regardais
batman la série animée et jeu qui fait
ça allez c'est bon retour à l'épisode eu
là j'ai juste envie de voir à quel point
ils ont profané leurs cadavres
allez on en est où donc alors voilà
pendant que splinter donc fait une
overdose le vieux maître envoie son
mystérieux messager encapuchonnés à new
york et osasuna ce qui est tortueux
qu'on a vu dans le jeu d'eric par hasard
bien tu nies je ferai comme tu l'as
[Musique]
qu'on va avoir des tas et des tas de
blagues et des situations gênantes sur
le fait que ce soit la seule femelle du
groupe
tu es une mutante des teams sexy
d'ailleurs j'aimerais bien un petit
bisou rouge pas [ __ ] est-ce que c'est
pas totalement du harcèlement sexuel ça
je veux dire ça vous suffit pas d'en
faire une bande de gros bouffons plus
vous voulez qu'on en garde de
michelangelo une image de délinquants
sexuels
[Musique]
halliche à quel jeu il est passé des
pizzas aux niches haut en un épisode il
ne manque plus que le foot là je
voudrais vous aider toi et tes frères à
sauver maître splinter
merci mais on n'est pas des frères
tu veux dire qu'il n'ya aucune parenté
entre vous non nous ne sommes que des
tortues domestique mais est élevé dans
un élevage de torture comme toi quoi
alors je ne suis pas ta petite soeur non
toi et moi nous nous sommes qu'à mi
temps et une mes tantes
ok alors on va tout de suite la refaire
avec des sous titres alors je ne suis
pas ta petite soeur non toi et moi nous
sommes qu'à mi temps et une mais tente
sans lien de parenté sérieusement elle
vient de chine pour sauver le monde vous
avez pas mieux à faire
un scénario
[Musique]
et puis évidemment on plonge dans les
clichés regardez je suis une fille alors
je suis un peu maladroite je suis qu'à
côté je sais pas peut-être alors j'étais
pouvoir de filles louis philippe ier
thème 8 souvent deux filles bon au moins
1h raider faut regarder les aspects
positifs il y as raider il pue la merde
mais il ya chaleur mais je vais
t'écraser qui je te conjure de détruire
l'incarnation du mal que tu es debout
oh mon dieu ils ont tué freineur espèce
d'enfoiré non non non non non c'est pas
possible c'est pas vrai il est offerte à
l'honneur le nom n'existe calculé ils
vont pas tuer le méchant principal un
deuxième épisode c'est une blague
en plus c'est de la fin de shredder
littéralement baisse et c'est ça que
méchants traders c'est pas bien être
méchant ces primes et hop il dit [ __ ]
mais c'est quoi fin juin' ça c'est une
fille dont elle a le pouvoir de l'amour
ça y est non parce qu'il ya plus besoin
des tortues là c'est bon tu sembles
univers avec un pouvoir comme ça tu es
méchant on sait pas bien d'être méchant
ah ben si neymar en compte maintenant
[Musique]
attendez c'est pas fini je serai nourrir
via l'épisode 18 mètres shredder dans
son délire de devenir le maître du monde
a perdu tout sens des réalités est
devenu un vulgaire clochard way est il
sans même la literie rappelé mais vous
avez tué shredder de méchant préféré ça
vous suffit pas vous le ramener à la vie
pour le millier
[Applaudissements]
dites lui fait faire des travaux
d'intérêt généraux pour fêtera pas ch
raideur des ordures dans les égouts avec
les tortues ninja
non non non je refuse de voir ça vous
avez tué shredder il était mort
et vous l'avez tué ses os et de la
nécromancie reculer reculer cette série
c'est juste une tentative ratée de sexe
un terreau espèces en train sentai
japonais et les tortues ninja on a tous
les dialogues débile le costume de merde
les combats pour hisser le cimetière de
l'intelligence
on a un ennemi qui à sa tête qui selon
des chiottes
or on a des ennemis principaux rien sa
tête qui sort de la cuvette des chiottes
est-ce que j'ai besoin de dire autre
chose que ça et on l'a acheté ce truc et
ils viennent de ressortir l'intégrale
pour qui je sais pas mais on l'a acheté
oh là là on l'a même pas acheter [ __ ]
on la précommande est gelée reçu des one
[ __ ] offrir ça à quelqu'un à noël
c'est du même niveau que si tu chier
sous le sapin
alors on va passer rapidement sur les
autres trucs qui ont existé parce qu'on
peut pas vous laisser sur ça par exemple
le concert tortues ninja désolé pour la
qualité de l'image que je décrirais
comme une espèce de succession de
moments gênants que tu peux voir
l'énergie vitale des parents lentement
s'évaporer pendant que leurs lardons ne
comprennent rien ce qui se passe sur
scène avec les tortues qui ressemble à
des lézards maintenant morsay shredder
état est un chat
on
[Musique]
lockheed attend ce que je fous là
est ce que c'est à ce moment là que les
mecs du marketing se sont rendu compte
qu'ils sont allés trop loin
ok je sais que c'est un vieux rat mais
il ya vraiment besoin de faire chanter
comme un vieux rat aussi d'ailleurs il
ya aussi un making of du spectacle où on
peut voir comment les tortues ont
préparé leurs chansons
[Musique]
vous espérez sincèrement vous faire
croire que c'est vous qui jouez face à
la guitare de leonardo est là qu une
corde tu parles s'il joue l'anecdote il
ya aussi un tortues ninja spécial noël
regardez ils ont des tout petits
ces adorables je suppose
bref on a tout le temps d'aller au bardo
qui chante du reggae raphaël en ténor et
les plus belles tête de tueur toutes
séries confondues
on va bouffer tous ses enfants on va
aussi tué leurs parents
on va leur prêter les genoux et leur
chier dans le coup
par ailleurs je vais pas tout vous
montrer quand bien même j'adorerais
surtout pour la dernière chanson de
splinter qui consiste en une toute
petite dizaine de phrases mais répétés
en boucle pendant genre je sais pas
cette heure fait ça m'a semblé la
chanson c'est tellement gravées dans ma
tête que je jure que je pense qu'elle
s'est mélangé avec mon adn
cette chanteuse donc une dernière chose
avant de finir alors je sais pas trop
comment expliquer ça donc
[Musique]
mais celui ci n'a pas été gâté
comment
[Musique]
c
toronto
tha
[Musique]
geithner
ce n'est pas une parodie si cette voie
vous dit quelque chose c'est parce qu'il
a chanté ça
shana
donc l'histoire en bref c'est les
tortues qui reçoivent des cristaux donné
par une fée qui leur permettent deux
buts et en en personnage d'annie mais je
suis désolé j'ai pas comment le dire
autrement
donc ceux des mutants qui bute encore et
pourquoi pas est aussi peuvent fusionner
et devenir et au mieux tu es ok japon tu
repars chez toi si tu fais n'importe
quoi là c'est en fait vous savez il ya
une technique très saine dans les vidéos
pour voir si c'est de la merde tu
avances de 10 minutes au pif regarde ça
en moins de dix minutes le monde a été
détruit shredder est devenu un robot
dinosaures qui balancent des cananéens
et la torture blanche super mutation se
bat dans l'espace contre une succube
sexy en robe latex de couleur de
dominatrice à celle arrête alors du
décès non on n'a pas vu l'épisode de
encore eu de son corps de l'espoir n'est
pas mort
15h49 je teste ce métier
[Musique]
c'était sympa il va y avoir la
patrouille de france
c'est une chair je vais voir le dernier
film tortues ninja au cinéma j'espère
qu'il sera bien le boss christmas
d'autonomie avis trouvaient à bord
[Musique]
en plus d'eux
vaduz
oui nous sommes fait peur
et en plus de tout ce que vous risquez
votre avec force
hadopi